hi everyone my name is Matthew Rockland
i'm a boudreaux software developer I
work on a particular library for
parallelism called asked if you were in
the last section may be heard about that
okay I'll try it again how's this great
this tutorial was originally built with
a few different library developers I'll
work on different parallel programming
libraries and the intention was to talk
about parallelism in general so that
people can have a better understanding
about how to choose sort of the right
framework for their computation and
about how to reason about parallel
computing generally so it's not about
any particular tool it's about sort of a
variety of tools and more generally
about how to think about parallel
programming so you came here looking for
a dance tutorial it's not it renews
mostly mundane technologies there are a
few web pages you should know first
there's this github repository which has
some materials some notebooks also some
insulation instructions inside the
instructions it says to download
anaconda please do not do that we've
noticed that there's relatively low
bandwidth in this this room so if you
need to download Conda download mini
Conda instead or we actually have a
cluster setup for you with everything
you need so you can do that too but some
people like to play along they'd have
everything on the local laptop just so
when they walk out of this room they're
still well served so you can do that you
can follow these instructions on how to
continuity you can try using pip as well
where you can download mini Conda which
is a small pond installation if you want
to test things or the libraries that
should be working then great so the
other web page you should be aware of is
trying to get a better name for this but
big fat integral net without to give
this under a better domain but if you
press this button it will launch for you
a four node cluster on Google few
dungeon this will have all libraries you
need all the data sets you need it'll
have spark running it'll have asked
running levithan purloined and so if you
don't want to install stuff locally or
if there's a low bandwidth you can just
click that button at
fat integral net that thing is also
inside the chat room the chat room is
here get er Dai m / task / PI data GC
2016 and that has all the links i've
just mentioned except for itself because
it'd be sort of silly okay within so
either you've started a jupiter notebook
server on the local machine or you are
clicking that button and there are a few
different places you can go you want to
go to the directory named pie that IDC
2016 i'll have a sequence of notebook so
we're going to run through i'm going to
go through the first three and erin go
through the last three minor sort of
generally about how to think about
parallel programming and errands are
about actual problems so we're gonna
wait a few minutes we'll get set up on
that if you have questions please wave
your hands wildly ask questions on the
Gator chat or if you're totally fine ask
your neighbors if they need help maybe
you also go into Gator chat so we're
going to come back and around five
minutes make sure everything's okay
probably
okay so some additional administrative
notes there's a few different wireless
networks that are available to you one
is gassed BYOD which I hear is fairly
terrible there's no one see one coders
which is better but has a password that
password is unhelpfully in the get er
chat so if you have a friend nearby who
does have entered access you should ask
them that password and then also if
you're a capital one employee using your
own internet lucky you you actually
can't access this cluster it's not using
HTTPS all right no cap one employees
usual issah Darren ok I'm going to start
uh going now you can feel free to ignore
me I'm to talk for around 10 minutes
maybe exercises we're in a swap between
slides explanation and exercises always
going to sit down unfortunately because
the sort of the mics are set up so we're
talked about a few different things in
the first section we're talking about
three different ways of thinking about
parallel computing first parallel map
which is just applying one function to
lots of things this is a pretty common
case I left files I want to analyze them
all option two is submit which is sort
of fully free lots of parallels and how
you want to set it up and then three is
sort of big collections things like
spark I'm a producer to ask that give
you you know a few big operations you
can use you to rewrite your
accommodation terms of that we go
through those three things and hopefully
the next 30 or 40 minutes this tutorial
was originally a three hour long
tutorial presented at Syfy this year so
if you were go home and one look at the
full thing you can go on YouTube was
presented with benzaclin who's online on
guitar helping us out Sosa person who
built the cluster for you and then
Reagan Kelly of Jupiter so pops go down
so first bit there first three notebooks
were map submit and collections so map
we often have code that looks like this
we have some list of inputs you want to
apply some function on to all those
inputs and produce illicit outputs this
might be a bunch of log files I want to
parse might be a bunch of CSV files I
want to do some pandas codon etc we
might use this comprehension instead or
if we're sort of cool we might use this
map function which some people might not
usable don't the map function is
interesting because we can redefine this
map function make it a parallel map so
most parallel frameworks all parallel
frameworks which include some sort of
map function so things like concurrent
futures or thread pools things like
spark right by the apparel Lord ask
things like job lib okay so gently how
this works is that we import some
library we create some object and that
object has its own map and so we replace
instead of the pure python map we
replace it with you know our library
where this might be some smart cluster
it might be some thread pool that might
be something else okay so the first
notebook we have is all the topic of map
this is sort of the very common case
just show of hands who here has used
some pearl library to map over function
over data in parallel using that ok run
twenty percent of the room how about
something more complex than map maybe
about ten percent of the room okay this
is a pretty common case this is a good
tool to have in your belt this solves
honestly like eighty percent of parallel
programming problems it will need of
course you computer Nonis good cluster
this solves most of them okay so before
we start we're going to generate some
data so we have some fake stock data
this amount you know two megabytes of
historical daily average data direction
we generating this on like a 10-second
interval basis it'll look like real data
but it's definitely fake so there we go
it's you know doing what a bunch of work
is all happening in parallel interested
in well this producing is producing a
directory with a bunch of data for us
both and csv format and
json format so the data set we're going
to be working with for the first two
notebooks first three notebooks trend
local machine you've downloaded like to
megs of data and is now expanding out to
like an uncomfortable gigabyte okay so i
have a bunch of file names bunch of
files of JSON data okay and so these are
all for a bunch of different stocks so
apples in here yo ham Jen etc and what I
want to do is I want to let's increase
the size here and what we're going to do
in this first example is we're going to
load up each file read it in as JSON
turn into a panda's data frame and then
write it out as a hdf5 file and what
it's doing is just changing the data
format JSON is really slow to work with
HD IO is really fast so after do this
stuff that's interesting after we did a
step everyone all of our future
companies will be faster okay so this is
run sequentially right we see it
processing through this data set one
file at a time I'm just using a for loop
this is the kind of code we'd like to
accelerate while it does that means from
all files yeah well it does that were
like some other options so as we saw we
there's a few kinds of writing the sort
of it was embarrassingly parallel
company janitor is sort of do this
computation many many times as a future
ways of writing that one we can use map
and when we use something like map we
often need to take whatever we're doing
inside the for loop and bring it out as
a separate function so in this example
all of this code in the for loop and the
body of the for loop we need to make
that into a single function that we can
call over each element your data set
after we pull that data our flood code
out to some function we can use map and
we can use parallel
okay so that took a while we should sort
of get the feeling that I was at a
somewhat painful so as an example let's
look at a much simpler code so it's
gonna record it present a complex real
world example we're going to switch to a
toy example have an exercise a short
exercise to solve that that toy problem
we're gonna use that same approach to
solve the real world problem so use our
Tory problem we're calling sleep eight
times one after another and what we want
to do is we want I wanted to call that
in parallel so we're going to take the
body of this code which does two things
one it sleeps and then to it adds one to
some input never to that into a function
so this is concerning and so hopefully
the body of this for loop which took
eight seconds and this function should
look similar to you we've pulled the
body out into a separate function so
that now we can create a process pool
executor which is something from the
concurrent futures module which is
available in sort of this is in the
standard library and then rather than
call us in a for loop we're going to use
that objects map function so we have
this function we have a list of inputs
just range eight every fall map on those
and so we're still calling that function
eight times we're calling it in parallel
with a bunch of course this machine has
I think like 16 cores on it and so it
ran in about a second around all of them
at the same time okay so there are two
steps one we made a process pool
executor so we can copy paste and then
too we took the body of this for loop
and made it into a separate function
then we called nap that function and
that list of inputs so back to our
original example we have our sequential
code which takes a while to run then we
want to just parallel as this so we want
to pull out the body of this function
you probably take you a file name as an
input and we're going to create a
possible executor
and then call a map of that function on
all of our file names okay that's our
first exercise let's try that for a bit
and if you have questions recession
alligator chat or wave your hands will
come by a help out ok I'm going to keep
moving along I was a fair amount of
material to cover here so some of this
might be abbreviated so we can run that
sequentially or we can so that also all
the solutions are already present here
so I get the impression that someone
else is on this cluster which is
confusing yeah yeah so your clusters are
all built with with Cooper Nettie's so
on Google Pete engine there's system
that can like spawn up all of what you
want when you click that button which is
neat and so we should all be entirely
isolated but getting this weird
okay great so here's a solution so we
took the body of the for loop out made
it a separate function this function
which takes in one of the file names we
also created a process pool executor
then we're just mapping that function
across all different file names so we
can go ahead and we can we can time how
long this takes and this is going to run
in parallel using all the cores on my
machine and it took two seconds which is
a lot faster than what we saw previously
this is again the common case most
parallel computing problems sort of fall
under this pattern I've got all this
data I have this function I want to run
run on top of all that data go many
frameworks implement some sort of map
you're using concurrent features but
again most parallel computing frameworks
implement some sort of map okay present
isn't everything this combination can be
equally well accelerated just by using a
faster JSON library so just a quick
reminder that you know parallelism can
solve your problems but also just being
a slightly smarter about libraries you
use more about your algorithms can help
just as much with much less pain okay so
that's map again common case really
useful sometimes you have computations
that are clearly parallelizable but
don't fit into this sort of standard map
paradigm for example i have this nested
for loops or I'm sort of looking
iterating over to collections and then
comparing elements within those
collections and depending on if it's you
know one is grim the other I'm calling F
or I'm calling G so it's a bit more
logic here right it's not just mat and
it's sort of it's tricky to think about
how I might you know write this code
using one of these higher level
frameworks in these cases it's nice to
have a fallback something that I can use
to do parallelism without needing to use
a big operation like a map or a group by
so for that there's something called
submit inside that same current view
library submit is also is this Empress
also met inside of the things like
concurrent futures ordaz represent
parallel and multiprocessing now let's
just do parallel computing sort of
arbitrarily structured computations so
it's nice when sort of you have obvious
parallelism but it's not clear how to
write that parallelism in terms of a
framework so how submit works is that
we're going to have some sort of system
you build like a concurrent futures
executor and we're going to submit one
function on top of some arguments and
this is just a single function call
happening at some other process or in
some other thread or on the oral and
some other computer and I can call that
many many times and rather than that
running the function immediately in the
blocking it gives me some sort of future
some sort of promised that i can use get
a result when it's finished later on I
can call result on that future to wait
until that result actually finishes in
the meantime I can do lots of other
stuff for example I can call submit many
many times so here's one way in which
you can implement map using submit
submit is sort of a fine-grained version
so here I'm submitting a function on
many elements of an input list and
appending all of those features to sound
list this happens more or less
immediately and then while we're sort of
doing other things may be checking your
email maybe we're like plotting
something all of some other resources
computing those functions for us and
then they come back when we call results
ok so our previous example of this code
that was clearly had implicit
parallelism but wasn't clear how to use
map we can every time we wanted to call
a function like f we can replace it with
a call to submit where submit takes as a
first argument the function we wanted to
call as the rest of the arguments the
argument that we would have given to
that function so it's kind of we're just
moving this parenthesis over here to the
left of f
so this code starts everything running
in parallel and then we need to call
results on all of our futures to
actually wait for them to finish so
submit is a pretty powerful tool you can
do it to sort of anything you want to
get parallelism out and it handles that
for you so that's good in cases where
map doesn't fit any quick questions on
that do you have a question probably
take a lad also have that question so i
would love have one person ask a
question yes yeah so the question is is
this always forking memory so i've got a
lot of data inside my notebook session
is that going to cause problems an
answer is that so first submit isn't as
an abstract API just like map so map
militant many different ways for example
there's a thread there's a thread pool
executor which will use operate in the
same thread the same same process and so
the interfaces we're showing here we're
going to use concurrent futures to play
with them but they could be implemented
in many different ways we don't really
know how we don't really care it's sort
of up to the library framework to take
care of it in practice you don't need to
worry it's going to be fine if you're
using the process pool executor which is
what we'll use in a moment it will it'll
fork but that'll be probably
copy-on-write so you'll be fine you'll
be moving stuff over over a wire for
your data inputs but don't worry about
it in practice don't worry about it
it'll be fine okay
yeah so a second question submit like
triggers competition immediately write
the answers again it depends on the
framework implementing it threadpool
executor possible executor have a queue
of work so it'll you know it's going to
do eight things at once and i'll put
that onto the queue but let's move on to
the second notebook this submit notebook
okay so we have the same data set here
but now conveniently built as hdf5 files
from the last exercise if you didn't
finish last exercise just load the
solution cell and then run that it'll
create all this for you and we're going
to do is we're going to read in from
this tht fi files the closing price well
let's look at the status that just for a
moment so let's look at series I think
Apple
okay so this is the closing price of
apple stock over lots of time so we have
inside of this dictionary the closing
prices a lot of stocks a lot of me maybe
similar stocks maybe the similar stocks
over a span of time something you often
want to do with a sort of data is you
want to see how well they're correlated
or maybes find a couple of companies
that seem to be correlated very strongly
so in the future maybe one goes up you
would maybe you know invest more than
the other one so one thing I want to do
is I might want to find the two stocks
that are the most correlated so here I'm
going to do a few things I'm going to
again in a sort of sequential code here
this thing we're going to paralyze in a
bit we're going to iterate over all the
file names twice and they are not the
same we're going to compute the
correlation of one series with the other
this is using the pandas correlation
method it was a bunch like a little bit
of time not too long about you know one
and a half seconds and this this code is
you know parallelizable but it would be
tricky to do with map so instead we can
use the same trick we did with submit to
to paralyze this code so you're seeing
something like correlation now to write
a function and then submit that function
work sorts thing okay so it looks like
there are two stocks that are pretty
well correlated you can see there a sort
of correlation here so once where to
find these stocks so again our
computation starts out embarrassingly
parallel this is something we could do
easily with map reloading in data from
hdf5 file many hd5 files then to EE
nested loop with an if statement inside
of it this is maybe harder to use math
for there's more complexity here and
then finally there's a reduction on all
of our correlations to find the best one
and this is something that is just not
very parallelizable it's not a it also
isn't very it wasn't very slow so we
don't really need to paralyze this
they're going to work on is this middle
part which is maybe the hard part
so this submit function if we have a
function like slow add which waits for
some time about a second then returns
the sum of two numbers we can call that
normally or we can call it with submit
you may notice that this ran instantly
right immediately returned and the state
of that future was running but now
asynchronously that competition is
finished so is running in a separate
thread somewhere and if you want to even
get the result back three okay so this
is concurrent futures with submit which
is a handy interface that have so we did
it's just with one single computation
but could on this many many many times
for example we can call slow out here to
this comprehension just normally on 10
numbers and that's going to take roughly
10 seconds because it's going to delay
one second for every slow odd call or in
this second cell we can submit slow add
get back ten futures this line will
finish you know within a couple
milliseconds then we're going to wait
until we have all the results back
that'll take and however long we need
you to take this machine has I think a
number of friend of coors we started a
thread pool executor with I think for
four threads and so it looks like you
know it did for of the calls i did for
more calls into two more calls as it
took three seconds tool
why
this is a function that I will fall
right slow add
that's a great question Erin sirens
question is you know so I sort of gay I
want to call this thing I want to call
slow out and one and one so why I
normally in Python I i say the function
name i put a parenthesis I've been its
mark you meant to the closing
parenthesis thing is if I do that right
now it's going to call that function and
submit will never actually get access to
run that instead so we can't just call
it immediately that will instead trigger
combination side of our local thread
which is bad won't get any parallelism
so we need to sort of do this trick
where we instead give submit the
function we want to call and then
separately all the arguments we want to
call it with and then it's going to do
the actual calling of things on its own
somewhere it said some other thread with
this when the process on some other
machine so a common mistake though is to
do what erin was just talking about
which is to actually call slow out in
here you can't do that that's a common
mistake second
yeah so right so if we were to do this
slow dad's going to run and it's going
to produce two and then we're going to
go call a dot Simenon to which is not
going to be of much use so yeah that's a
great pretty equation so we always put
in the function and then the arguments
and the keyword arguments if we need to
but we never actually call the function
immediately ok so exercise we have a
couple of different functions here slow
add and slow sub and we have some
sequential code and we need to use
submit inside of the sequential code to
instead produce not a list of results
but a list of futures okay this is going
to be very similar to the Kobe are doing
up here but now it's something that you
have to do in a small exercise if you
need to other solutions on here so let's
spend a few minutes on that if you
finish early your actual full exercise
is down here and it's mostly the same
thing but this time on actual data so
let's spend a few minutes and work on
this this exercise and I'll be back in a
bit okay I'm going to move on so here's
my solution to that problem so we're
going to submit the functions slow at
and slow sub rather than call them
directly into a list of futures and so
each of these objects so here's submit
returns for a sub object a future object
which is something we can use to get the
actual result when it's finished and so
futures is a list of these two this
futures list here is a list of these
future objects and this code finishes
immediately and gives us this list now
what actually happened right so we're
using the thread pool executor and so
there's maybe you know four different
threads they're all watching some cue
whenever we call submit we're putting a
function in some data into that Q and
the threads are pulling from that queue
and doing work when they finish they put
the results on to the few
sure object and so we can call result on
that future object until we wait and get
the result so we can run this that runs
you know faster than would have run
otherwise ok we can do the same thing
with our actual computation so here this
ran in about one and a half seconds for
a solution we're going to so this one's
a little bit tricky right because we had
this method here I'd really know how to
submit methods that's a little bit a
little bit more awkward so instead we
make a little function correlation
function which takes in two inputs and
calls the correlation method on them
it's the same exact pattern we run it
it ran in about you know half the time
that's actually wasn't a whole lot
faster right this is maybe twice as fast
and not you know four times or ten times
as fast and this computation this
correlation computation isn't very isn't
very computationally intense so it does
it's not easy to make it fast so it's
worth noting that a lot of pearl
computing really just helps you with
using multiple CPUs but that might not
be your but your bottleneck may be
bottlenecked on disk in Iran disk i/o on
the network on memory on other things
someone else in the corner also asked
hey you know your these the correlation
is symmetric right so it actually a lot
faster if you were to just only consider
a half of these pairs so we don't need
to consider a and B and then be than a
the correlation be the same we need to
consider you know one one of those Paris
and so we could got in the same speed up
just by being a little bit smarter about
our problem and then we do not think
about futures or threads or anything we
could it has been a little bit smarter
so again always think about your
competition before you paralyzed as an
exercise now there's threads and
policies a good rule of thumb is if
using numpy pandas scikit-learn numba
any sort of Scythia eyes code you should
be using threats this reduces memory
moving data between processes which is
expensive and python is very good at
parallelism for numeric code and threats
if using Python code pure python code
like dictionaries and lists and sets
remember using processes this is because
of the Gil you can sort of look online
about what that is but numpy pandas
threads pure python processes you can
break this in fun ways okay so that's
submit and again submit is good for sort
of unstructured computation there's a
middle ground which is sort of big
collections so things like spark rdd
zord ask data frames or bags or arrays
where you have some large abstraction
like all of my data is
big table or is a big array where's a
big list and then you are restricted to
a few operations things like group by or
shuffle or map or filter and you
construct your computation with those
big operations and that framework
provides for you a few things you can do
that are safe and everything else is
sort of not safe so if you can rewrite
your computation in a few of these sort
of patterns something sort of semi
structured collections might be a good
choice so in sort of a middle ground
between map which was just one pattern
and fully fully sort of restrictive you
do one thing submit which is sort of
anything you want to do you can do and
the sort of middle ground of you have a
few different operations you can use and
you try to compose your your algorithm
in terms of those operations so this
works in lots of cases like for you know
sequel databases or for data frames if
your data if your combination fits
inside of that bolt we're running a
little bit of a long time so the next
exercise you can do in either spark or
desk that'll look mostly the same I'm
news I work on desk so I'm use spark
just to be sort of egalitarian but
there's like a one word difference
inside of these two so we have this the
same sequential code from before where
we are it's let's make a copy
so we have the same code from before and
we can think about some of some of the
spark operations like map or Cartesian
products or filter or max anything about
how to rewrite our for loops in terms of
those operations so just to get sort of
a brief example of how that works so I
make a little spark contacts takes a few
seconds if I have you know a spark rdd
so ardd is like a parallel collection
it's like a list that is you know maybe
on my machine or maybe a mutual
processes on different computers and I
can make one by you know in a simple
sense by sort of calling this paralyzed
method I can gather it back by call and
collect there's some overhead here but
it's it's fine I can do things like map
where I'm going to map a function across
all of my data so previously I had this
RTD now contains all of my numbers one
through five I can call map on it and
that gives me another rdd or i can call
map and then collect that gives me our
results back so just like concurrent
futures sparkle to provide the snap
function again so it is i fathom
parallel so does job live so it is task
lots of things filter I can sort of
select a particular elements I want to
remove from my collection or keep in my
collection sorry I'm selecting only the
even elements and Cartesian product is I
have this list 1 3 or 5 and make a tuple
with all possible combinations so 0 0 0
1 0 to 10 11 12 etc and so using map and
Cartesian and filtering employees other
things so we can start to chain these
operations together so here I'm going to
scroll of elements and then going to
sort of consider the product with my
original data set and I'm going to
filter out the elements where the second
one is even then collect and so again if
you can sort of think with these sort of
big operations in our heads so map
pretty sure product filter group by join
then we can use systems like spark
or sparked out of framers dust at our
friend so now we have this problem we
need to look at our sequential code this
sort of nests of for loops this
condition and then applying this
function and think about how to apply
how to rewrite this in terms of the
operations we've just seen rhodesian
product map filter etc some sort of pie
spice work here happening well okay so
when are we out of here what's the try
to figure out a schedule 1215 okay want
to go play with that while Aaron and I
switch out and the Aaron will talk about
some other materials too so I'll give a
brief sort of fine a little bit on this
bit so we've seen a few different ways
of thinking about parallel computation
we've seen map on one end we've seen
submit on the other end map is just does
the common case it's really good in most
of the cases submit is completely
freeing and it looks a lot like your
Python code and the sort of middle
ground of playing with these sort of
libraries that give you a fixed set of
things you can work with and if you're
you know depending on your problem you
might choose one solution or the other
that fits well all of these kinds of
algorithms have been implemented in many
different ways you can use these all of
these on your local computer you can use
all of these on a cluster so you don't
to choose one of the other based on your
hardware you can choose these based on
your computation it's a good way of
thinking about you've got to be comin
problem okay where do I sort of fit and
then I can separately find some tool
that matches that algorithm type on my
hardware so if I'm on a single machine i
just wanna use map maybe you concurrent
futures is enough maybe that's good it
was really simple it's really as you use
done if I want to use a cluster and I
want to use submit well let's see i
press on apparel does that and ask does
that sort of literature to those two if
I want to use collections on a single
machine I've got a few options Bonnie's
questions on a cluster
also have a few options things like
Sparkman task so so you sort of break
coaches in those boundaries with it okay
Aaron do want to set while people try
out this exercise rewriting this for
loop code using the sort of spark
primitives and again if user to can't
get that the solution is available we're
going to move forward onto notebook for
which is the cross-validated parameter
search okay so i'm going to wait for a
minute for everybody to get that
notebook up and then I'll start talking
I think I also need to be speaking into
this mic so that's a balance they soon
it's okay so if you're in the PI data DC
2016 folder it's going to be numbered
for if somehow you ended up in the other
folder that's okay the notebooks are the
same just make sure you're in the
cross-validated parameter search
notebook okay so go ahead and raise your
hand if you've got that notebook up
raise your hand if you need some more
time okay so I'm gonna move forward and
I'm gonna let a mat and Hussein help out
with anybody who still needs some time
Hussein is joining us that he's already
been voluntold okay cross validate
parameter search so who here is does
model fitting wish I could learn so who
here has done a parallel model fit what
scikit-learn who here has done a
parallel model fit with scikit-learn on
a cluster with the hyper parameter
search okay I think I've seen one person
at the end of this exercise you will all
have done a parallel hyper parameter
search for a model fit on a cluster okay
actually you'll have done it on a node
but the steps to go from an ode to a
cluster win in desk or trivial so we're
going to talk through this
go ahead do I have a mic I am Mike you
know there's probably just no speakers
on that end of the room so I can switch
mics with Matt let's try this I can
shout too but if I shout I have to keep
turning my head left and right do you
guys prefer shouting or miking okay let
me just switch mics and see if that
works
of course
okay am I miked on the right side yeah i
er nice okay just to recap when I said
for the last two minutes we're going to
do a parallel hyper parameter fit you
don't know what that is don't worry
about it it's basically we're going to
search over a set of parameters in a
model fit to find the best possible one
so this is a task that's trivially
parallelizable and yet we never paralyze
it and so sometimes you'll have vast
computing resources available to you and
yet you still won't be doing things
faster because you haven't been able to
paralyze things until now so here we go
we're going to walk through this we're
going to start with the problem that you
may have seen I think for a lot of you
this is going to be familiar this is
just the digits data set in scikit-learn
so if you've worked in psych it learned
before you'll have worked probably with
this data set if you've trained a
classifier at some point or another I am
waiting for this to execute
okay los the kernel for a moment there
and its back okay so this is the problem
you have go ahead Smallville's the okay
so you should not be in PI data DC you
need to go back to the DEP there's a
pile of a failed to move because we were
reading before it's cv5 ketchup pal we
did okay sorry so Matt just instructed
me that I failed to move it a file over
last night when you're getting this
tutorial ready so the easiest way to do
this is to go back up to this cluster
controller head to the notebooks
directory and then head to to number 5
cross-validated parameter search and I
will fix this after the tutorial if you
head into this the correct directory
okay
so just taking a quick look what we're
looking at is a set of data where we
have handwritten digits and we know that
we want those digits to go to map from 0
to 9 and so for each of this digits
probably the best guess here is that
this was a 0 for example but we want to
do this by hand we want the computer to
do this for us so if you step forward
this import should work if it didn't
work you need to move over to the other
notebook directory again come up to the
home go into the notebooks directory
instead of the PI data DC 2016 and then
open notebook 5 cross-validated
parameter search okay so here's the
parameter space there's a couple of
different parameters used and I believe
that this is a support vector classifier
yeah so there's a couple of different
parameters that show up in a support
vector classifier I believe that C is
the penalty parameter gammas the colonel
coefficient this one's actually
relatively important as the stopping
criterion the default that a library
like scikit-learn gives you may not
actually be suitable for your use case
right so you may actually want a model
that has a really tight convergence or a
really tight attempt at eric convergence
and so depending on what your criterion
you may need to change this tolerance so
don't just always rely on the defaults
don't even necessarily rely on what
comes out of the hyper parameter space
take a minute and think about what your
actual loss function is and what you're
trying to get to this is a little bit of
a preview for a talk that's coming up on
Sunday by Chris White so if you have
some more thoughts about that you can
come see him after the talk or you can
go and go watch this talk in the
afternoon okay so obviously when you
train a model you don't want
to train on your test data you split it
so you have a cross-validation set
second learn makes that easy and what
we've done in this CV params demo file
is we've done some of the work ahead of
time for you in terms of splitting this
data set up so that you can work or
operate on individual pieces of the
cross-validation set okay so we have a
training set and now what we're going to
do is we're going to run through this
parameter space just sequentially and
did I miss something so again oh oh that
so a quick way to not execute this
correctly so this is a coarse-grained
search that we executed in cereal and
we're doing it slowly because we're
doing it insert we're doing a small
course search because we're in cereal so
the exercise here so this is just a
quick plot of the parameter space that
we're searching over so you'll find that
these in the lower right are the better
solutions but we don't really have a
good understanding of what this space
looks like and so we can do a much more
high resolution parameter search if we
do it in parallel so again this is the
the number that you may want to increase
this is so this is just a pair of split
so you could have more splits and then
this is a parameter grid that we have
sort of a 10 by 10 and again once you
have this in parallel you will increase
this so that you can have a more high
resolution sure there's two solutions
here that you can look at but why don't
you start as an exercise now try and
apply all the things that you've learned
in the first 45 minutes with Matt if you
get stuck you can either talk to a
friend you can raise your hand or you
can look at the solutions files
so there are two solutions that have
been saved to you and are already
available what I'm going to do is I'm
going to paste into the get er room my
password this is a solution that does
the hyper parameter search in parallel
on the cluster so i'm going to show you
the differences between this solution
and the solution one which is ok I'll
just load it into another cell so we can
look at them next to each other oh it's
just this all above I see it now ok ok
so this is the original solution you all
have this in front of you you can pull
up a thread pool executor or a process
pool executor both would work and then
here's the work right you submit a
function that evaluates a single sort of
model fit right that's what the evaluate
one is doing is just taking a specific
set of parameters and is trying to fit
the model there and then it's depending
that result in to the list of futures
and then it's just forcing these results
to return it's going to block on all the
results here in this last bit this is
that solution but now it's been I we can
say desk if I'd right ok so instead of
using a thread pool executor we say from
dash distributed import executor and
progress is just a little bit of sugar
here that makes it easier to see how
things are going and detect if there's a
problem and of course this code is going
to work for you as well because you have
if you have a cluster up so if you're
logged into big fat integral you'll be
able to execute this you set up a equals
executor
9000 that's just telling the schedulers
what port to look for and where to go
okay this upload file is there because
the CV params demo I is not on the other
cluster note and so one thing that you
can do is if you have some data like
some lightweight data or you have a
python module that need to ship over
just while you're sort of testing things
out you can actually send this thing up
to all of the nodes this isn't sort of
what you would do in production it's
just something that you would do while
you're playing around and then
everything else looks the same the code
actually hasn't changed so if you got
something in parallel and you tested it
out and you were comfortable to wave it
was working you could actually take this
code and then put it on a cluster and
run it in parallel and you'll get the
speed up from the cluster and of course
the API is the same sometimes things
will subtly change and it won't work but
at least you'll be able to write code
that looks the same or very familiar and
test it out and work on it locally
before you go on to a big cluster ok so
there's also a spark solution down at
the bottom and I don't know if anybody
tried it should work ok any questions
about this before I move on I know this
is we probably gave this thing not even
a tenth of the time it deserves there's
a lot to explore here yeah did you have
to start something on port 9000 like the
separate process so the processes were
already running when the cluster I
started we started them up for you go
ahead
sure
Oh
run
ok
one of the box
we didn't save it as a results we just
kept it here I got ya all right just
needed to
yeah so this line here don't worry about
it too much it's just it's just a way
it's it's actually almost assumed that
the schedulers are going to be running
on this port it's just set up for the
desk parallel cluster go ahead I don't
know he's saying that the desk solution
is four times faster than spice Park I
wouldn't i wouldn't take those numbers
too seriously we actually get really
critical of folks who don't benchmark
properly you're on a cluster with share
a tendency so I yes in this particular
case it probably is faster remember the
PI spark has to cross the Java Python
boundary every time data comes in and
out and that's going to slow it down
especially for sort of smaller workloads
where there's a lot of communication
versus computation but yeah there's no
claims about speed of desk versus pi
spark in this tutorial you can okay I'm
gonna move on before we get into
dangerous territory okay so the final
thing I wanted to show you is
distributed data frames it's number
eight in the notebooks and basically
what i'm going to do is just for the
next five minutes I'm gonna just talk a
little bit about this this cluster is
going to stay up after this tutorial
ends and through lunch so you may need
to log in and create a new cluster
because I believe they're expiring
they're not expiring after 30 minutes
okay keep your current thing up don't
listen to me um okay so now we're going
to talk about a different type of
analysis what we started before was we
already had our data loaded and what we
wanted to do was we wanted to fit a
model now as anybody here who has ever
worked with the data set can tell you
ninety percent of the effort is just
getting it into memory and in the shape
that you want it to be in right it's
over a gigabyte or if it's over 10
gigabytes all of a sudden all of your
standard tricks start getting really
painful so what we're going to show you
how to do here is to actually bring data
in into a appendage like data frame in
desk so the tool that we're using is
desk data frame it's very similar as
well to what sparks concept about our DD
is or a distributed data frame but we to
whatever extent possible use the same
interface as pandas so there's some
things that are going to be missing
you're not going to have everything but
you're going to be able to use a lot of
the same ideas and so if you're just
exploring some data or trying to get it
you know from one state into another
this is a really good place to start so
the first thing that we're doing here is
we're looking at the New York taxi cab
data set they're stored as a bunch of
CSV files on s3 and we see that if we
tried to just pull one of these in with
pandas it would be pretty painful right
so that's not really showing you how
hard this is but this is what the data
looks like so instead we're going to use
a parallel task execution context and
we're going to read those CSV files
again that reads CSV should look
familiar it looks like pandas read CSV
there's one more thing in here this
storage options and I'm not going to go
into it but that's add a specific
keyword for loading parallel data okay
so it didn't actually finish load
just in that call everything by default
in desk there's two things it's lazy and
it's non blocking so lazy means that
it's not going to execute until you tell
it to non-blocking just means that it's
going to come back a result is going to
come back that may not be the result it
just says I executed this thing so
remember there's actually a difference
there so lazy means that it doesn't
start executing until you I tell it that
I need it non-blocking means I'm going
to get I'm interactive I'm going to get
something back right after I make that
function call so i can go and maybe
start doing something else so for
example if it's lazy i might say oh I
actually need you to actually compute
this so there's two ways you can tell
dass to compute you can say persist
which is do this thing oh go ahead I
should start this is what you're saying
okay so so there's do this thing and
then there's actually I want the result
back and so do this thing is an
execution call but it's not blocking
that's persist compute is blocking it
won't come back until it's actually got
a result and then it gives you that
result as well so there's more notes on
that in here but now I you actually have
this data frame up and you'll see this
progress is being called every time
we're doing an action just give you an
idea of sort of a sense of how tough
some of these computations are to
compute and how long they're going to
take we can look at for example we
pulled the fares out of the data frame
that we're positive that's the request
here that almost you know if you're
familiar with sequel but not super
familiar with Python or pandas this
starts looking a little bit you know
like a sequel like language that's
intentional right Anna's data frames are
sort of this in-between of arrays or
tabular data and sequel like or database
like access to your data okay so we can
take a sum of all of the fairs where the
taxicab driver got stiffed they didn't
get a tip okay and we can take a look at
the total number of fair
grace and we can take a look at the
total number of passengers right so
these are just easy reductions over the
entire data set ok so is 1215 I'm going
to turn it over to Matt I have to run
I've got another thing I've got to run
to it's been awesome this has been
really fun follow up with us come to the
happy hour tonight and thanks ok so I
think we're actually at time right
twirls are done now right I have you
stick around for questions we won't ask
questions but now it'd be a good time to
sort of finish up if you want to leave
the room they can leave the room in a
way that's yeah friendly and happy so
thank you all for coming I'll give
another talk on desk on Sunday that's
just much more than what we've seen here
and generally speaking this wasn't a
task talk this is a general perla
computing talk good remember that please
play around the stuff these clusters
will be up for the next you know day at
least so please play around it's a nice
chance to play with a lot different
tools have a nice environment that's
safe you can't break anything
everything's protected so do what you
want yeah thank you all for coming